- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is think about different ways
to represent multiplication.
And especially connect it to the notions
of skip counting and the number line.
So if we were to think about
what four times two means,
we've already seen in other videos,
you could view this as four groups of two.
So we could have four groups,
so one group, two groups,
three groups, and four groups,
and each of them have two of something.
I'll just put two little circles here.
So you have two there,
you have two there,
and you have two there,
and you could also view that
as four twos, or four twos added together.
So we could view it as two plus two
plus two plus two.
And this, of course, is going
to be two plus two is four,
four plus two is six,
six plus two is eight.
We see that over here,
we could even skip count.
Two, four, six, eight.
Four times two is equal to eight.
We can also think about
that on a number line.
So I'm gonna make a little
bit of a number line here.
And so we could imagine four
times two being, all right.
So this is one times two,
two times two,
three times two,
and four times two.
So we started at zero,
and we took four hops of
two along the number line
to end up at eight.
We went from zero to
two, four, six, eight.
We just skip counted our way to eight.
So if I were to ask a
similar question, actually,
let me draw a little series of hops,
and I want you to think
about it the other way.
What multiplication does that represent?
So let's say I start here
and then I'm going to hop like this.
So I'm gonna go there
and then I'm gonna go there.
I'm taking equal jumps every time.
Then I'm gonna go there.
Then I'm going to go over there.
So what would that represent,
if we used the same type of ideas
that we just thought about?
Well I went from zero to
four, eight, 12, 16, 20.
I'm skip counting by four.
So you could imagine this is
probably something times four.
Now how many hops did I take?
I took one, two, three,
four, five hops of four.
So this is five times four.
And we can see that we ended up at 20.
We could also view this
as being the same thing
as five fours or four plus four plus four
plus four plus four, and
you see that over here.
You have, we're starting
at zero, we're adding four,
then another four, then another four,
then another four, and another four.
We have five fours here.
Let's do one more.
So I'm gonna have a number line here
and think about what it would mean
to say, do something like
seven times three, times three.
Well, we could view that
as seven hops of three
starting at zero, seven equal hops.
So one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six, and seven.
We end up at 21, so this is equal to 21.
You could also view this
as we took seven threes
and added them together.
And you could also view
it as skip counting.
You went from zero to
three, six, nine, 12,
15, 18, and 21.
Now just out of interest,
what if we went the other way around?
What if we were to take
three hops of seven?
What would that be?
Well, we would start here
and so we would take our first hop
of seven right over there.
Get to seven, then if we
take another hop of seven,
we get to 14,
and then if we take another hop of seven,
we get to 21, interesting.
At least for this situation,
whether we took seven hops of three
or three hops of seven, we
got to the exact same value.
I encourage you to think about
whether that's always going
to be the case.
I'll see you in a future video.